channel wrestler it says but I can't
find in the record so we know we've
learned two things about you today
you're a little forgetful you left your
credential on as we came on camera and
you are adept at reading Wikipedia
terrible
he didn't think when that news broke on
Thursday nothing you could tell just as
he put that up he was thinking we're
taco fall was and rolled it over the
basket how about that motive to get to
the bucket by Edwards on a cut he's
dropped one pass a couple of dribbles
two points he plays I said it earlier he
plays with his chin uh a lot of guys in
this league who have and I'm not trying
to defend what he did the other night
because I was with you and Ryan the
whole way but there are a lot of guys
this league who have been agitators and
have made a living off of a plaintiff or
a couple of occasions but he played on
20 now that's chasing a basketball dream
if you're gonna play 22 teams he's been
with New Orleans since 2010 Edwards gets
the best he got 14 as quickly as it was
a six-point game the lead is 10 again
Edwards cleared some space and that's
all he needs pan last year carson
edwards turned into an easy basket for
Bruno Coppola Edwards spoon defenders in
front patty still cashes it in